good news is I still don't know how to
dress myself so there's room for
improvement everything sucks but the
good news is today's another episode of
good news this
this is where I just tell you about good
things that I found on the Internet I
didn't come up with any of these I just
stumbled upon them by sky who knows how
I get to anything on the internet how
did you get here
that doesn't matter just don't leave
here here is nice what's happening in
the world that is good but news is the
fifth harmony song you don't gotta go to
work work work work has been in my head
all day so all my anxiety about all the
work that I should be doing has a very
appropriate soundtrack good news is I
saw this story one of your Cooper gets
job as Chicago hotel's concierge what's
not good about that except if you need
the concierge just help to get
eyeglasses or anything but love in this
pug revealed to introduce the newest
member of our Park Hyatt family Park or
a five year old pug with special needs
adopted from our partners at polish
Chicago Parker enjoys a luxurious life
of sleeping behind the front desk
basking in the Sun and bringing joy to
visitors and colleagues alike well some
of those qualities sound like really
good concierge qualities good for you
Parker I hope you actually enjoy this
exploitation on the most adorable level
speaking of animals bringing joy to
humans good news is crispy bacon will
always bring me joy forever now to the
story of a pig that is inspiring others
one pump one pot-bellied pig has
certainly endured his share of problems
crispy bacon was born without me yeah
you have to read this story there's a
story when I was cooking around the
internet I thought I saw this headline
all shaped camera you throw up to take
photos but the good news is the actual
story line is the my old camera you
throw up in the air to take photos that
is good news though the first one can
you imagine and that's how stupid our
dumb world is that I thought that that
was an actual thing in camera that you
had to throw up today good news is this
is
headline that exists in the universe but
someone got paid to create I only Gomez
sizzles into red-hot dresses and enjoys
a national donut day treat news as
scandalous and enticing as that headline
is I did not click it so I don't know
what the treat is I do not know what the
Treatise good news is you're still here
good news is new emojis how these new
emojis are coming to all of our phones
and devices and the best news of all is
that potato is coming so finally I have
a very concise and accurate way to
describe my feelings to everyone
speaking of engaging through text
message my mom's that made these two
texts back-to-back over the weekend you
look beautiful today hey the news
tonight says there's a spam Museum if
you wanted to see the DNA test between
my mother and I to prove real related
that was it goodness is Cash's ass and
her personality are both incredible and
this Instagram course proves it she
responded to a hater your jackknife
seven six I see that you would very much
like me to know that you think I'm ugly
and also eight four well I understand
that that is your opinion but I disagree
I'm not perfect but I'm pretty magical
and also I am not in fact a [ __ ] also
bullying someone who struggled publicly
with body issues is pretty mean thank
God I'm in a place in my life where I
feel empowered to address your nasty
comments instead of letting them destroy
me so on behalf of anyone anywhere who
struggles with body image stop it my
body is not your business
in conclusion kiss my magical imperfect
ass I enjoyed that very much
oh speaking of great social media
messages - terrible awful sacks of human
being I read a story about a mom that
overheard a bunch of teenage girls in
the Starbucks talking like Shh teenage
girls and instead of berating them more
demeaning them in public Jordan them
three mini frappuccinos which
unbeknownst to her was probably the name
of the fairly shaker band and wrote them
a note that said
they're you today in Starbucks and
listen as you talk you three are
obviously pretty and hardworking I wish
your kindness matched your pretty
exteriors I heard you talk about a girl
who sang about being lonely in the
talent show and you laugh sounded so
mean and petty you are smart and you are
pretty it would take nothing from you to
also be kind that's that's good news
it's nothing from you to be kind it
takes so much from you to be a piece of
[ __ ]
good news is I saw this article on
Huffington Post everywhere all day let's
med students experience what it's like
to be 74 which seems to be a lot like
what it's like to be 13 you just want to
touch them
Timmy's also good news is Huffington
Post has an entire section of boys I
don't know if I mentioned that last time
and it's really it's so good they have
stories like your old rescuers reunite
crying otter pup with mom it's maybe too
good I couldn't click on that but if
you're into that kind of thing
Huffington Post has a whole good new
section I saw an article that says
Michelle Collins might be leaving the
view and the good news is I did not know
Michelle Collins was a host of the view
but it is apparently Emma Stone was not
quite like tennis so much so that they
needed a body double for her in the new
movie battle of the sexes where she
plays tennis legend Billie Jean King and
that's good news because the proofs that
Emma Stone is a human with flaws good
news is nutrition labels will now show
calories for the whole tub of ice cream
so we'll get to fully understand how
much of a monster we are and
self-awareness is always a good thing
good news is today I had a personal
epiphany that Gigi had be real it was
just the face morph of Jennifer Lawrence
really flipped so okay that's it for
this episode of good news is I hope that
this made you feel good in any way shape
or form let me know some good news that
you've heard recently good news we're
getting closer and closer to three
million subscribers here on the it's
grace Channel and we can get even closer
click Subscribe right now good news is
that's it we're done we're out of here
good news is this is it this is it's the
end of the video well it's done
no it's done I like this one good news
is I read this on reddit local Dennis is
trying to pass off the turd emoji as two
things there are so many questions about
this photo though there's so why is that
little girl of a black eye why is she
holding that sign who let her turn the
turd into space why is she staring so
deeply into my soul okay